Ay ne kadar güzelsiniz ya Selamünaleyküm
çok heyecanlandığımı söylemek istiyorum
ki normalde ben biliyorsunuz sahne
insanıyım Normalde benim işim bu yani
sahneye çıkmak ve insanlara bir şey
anlatmak benim size o kadar çok
ihtiyacım vardı ki çok geç geldiniz
buldunuz beni
şimdi çok üzgün olduğumu söylemek
istiyorum ama yine Elhamdülillah yine En
azından geldiğiniz buldunuz
ve sonra o kadar engellendim ve sonra
hiç o kadar kendime benim anlatacağım
hikayeleri beni dinleyecek seyirci
Bulamadım ki o yüzden
işte böyle
gördüğüm an diyorum ya galiba
bu olmuş Dualarım O yüzden Elinize
sağlık
konuşma boşuna başlamak istiyorum bundan
yaklaşık bir ay önce beni hepinizin
bildiği İstanbul'da çok iyi ilk üçte bir
üniversite en iyi çıkış yapan tiyatro
oyuncusu adayı seçti 35 yaşındayım
çıkış yapan diğer arkadaşlar 20
yaşlarının başında
Bakıyorum da yani
yine ezme olmuşlar şimdi ilk oyun
larını bana Ben 35 yaşındayım 36'ya
merdiven dayadım neden
Peki önce biz güldük falan eğlendik ama
sonradan bir böyle bir gece Yorganı
başıma çektiğim de bir iki damla
Gözyaşını dökmedim değil
Neden ben 20'li yaşlarımın başında çıkış
yapamadım
konservatuvardan mezun olm
ama rağmen çizili olmama rağmen niye ben
çıkışımı gerçekleştiremedim Niye ben
sesiniz size duyuramadım Neden şimdi
size böyle hepinize sarılacak gibi
bakıyorum Niye niye yani
bundan bahsedeceğim Ben okuldan mezun
olduktan sonra tabii ki yani
[Müzik]
beni tanıyanların bildiği üzere
tanımayanların da şimdi anlayacağı üzere
müteveleyin bir aileden daha
fazla olduğundan dolayı tiyatro camiası
bana birazcık Bunlar ne yapıyorlar ya
gibi geldi Tabii ki tiyatroyu çok
seviyorum
sahnede olmayı çok seviyorum yazmayı çok
seviyorum Kendi yazdığım karakterleri
oynamayı çok seviyorum
çok normal olarak yaşantı olarak bana
birazcık uzak gel o yüzden ben kendime
daha uygun tiyatrolar aramaya başladım
Bilin bakalım
var mıydı Sizce yoktu değil mi Şu an var
Şu an işte sizin de bildiğiniz birkaç
tane tiyatro var Elhamdülillah güzel
deyişler yapıyorlar yapıyoruz ancak o
zaman yoktu arkadaşlar O zamandan kastım
üniversiteye girdim onu da mezun oldum
yok
Bir Yanak koşuyoruz öbür yanak
koşuyoruz bir şeyler
yapmaya çağırın yakasını
anlatmıyor Çünkü zaten tiyatrocu
yetişmemiş
sanat
daha böyle şu anki kıvamında değil o
zamanlarda ne yapacağız Ne yapacağız
derken ne yapacağım derken
mecbur bir yandan da para kazanmam
gerekiyor Yani
faturalar ödenecek ben karnımı
doyuracağım Elimde bir hayatın var
vesaire bir de İnsan utanıyor biliyor
musunuz
sürekli babandan para istiyorsun sürekli
annemden para istiyorsun
Eee sinemaya gitmeye bile utandığımı
biliyorum çünkü sen para kazanmıyorsun
Ya sinemaya gitmek istediğim için niye
istiyorsun Sen babandan sinemaya gitmek
için
para Bundan dolayı
dönemler oldu Ee tabii ki çok şey dedim
hadi gelin hep beraber bir oyun yapalım
hadi gelin şu oyunu yapalım bu oyunu
yapalım Tabii ki yapamadık
Biz bilir tiyatro oyunu yapabiliriz ya
da ayrı inançları yok
Neyi nasıl yapılacaklarını bilmiyorlar
Bundan dolayı çok uzunca süre Arkadaşlar
ben böyle çok özür dileyerek söylüyorum
çok dandik tiyatro çocuk oyunlarında
oynaya oynaya oynaya oynaya çok büyük
bir kayboluş sürecinin içerisine girdim
İçinizde Bir Büyük Bir Hasret var
tiyatro yapmak istiyorsunuz tiyatro
yapan Arkadaşlarınızı görüyorsunuz Yani
biz çocuk tiyatrosu olarak arkaya şişme
dekor koyuyoruz Ee oynayacak oyun yok
işte ben koşuyorum Bir Genç Kadını
oynuyorum Sonra gidiyorum başıma bir
peruk takıyorum geliyorum yaşlı kadınla
oynuyorum o kadar iyi okulun
içerisindeyiz ama benim konservatuvardan
mezun olmuş diğer arkadaşlarım işte çok
büyük büyük sahnelerde büyük
prodüksiyonlarla sofita biz bu tavana
sof bunun iplerle şey yapıyorlar
uçuyorlar sahnede düşünebiliyor musunuz
Yani ben böyle
onları da kendi
oyunlarım Tabii bu süreç içerisinde
insanlar ne dediler
saçma sapan işlerle uğraşıyorsun bırak
şunları
ve bunun ne yazık ki benim eşim dostum
akrabalarım annem babam ablam abim de
söyledi yapma gel istersen bırak denedin
olmuyor
şöyle bir iş varmış şuraya seni
götürelim burada bir iş varmış Buraya
seni götürelim önce sevgili arkadaşlar
direndim çok güzel direndim Hayır dedim
ben tiyatro yapacağım ben bu kadar
eğitimi bunun için almadım ben tiyatro
yapacağım dedim dedim ama sonra
kiranızı ödemeye ödememeye
başladığınızda Şu an sizin için bu çok
önemli bir konu değil ama arasın
aramızda kiralık diyenler varsa
hocalarım değil mi kira ödemeye
ödeyemediğinizde Ne yapıyorsunuz her işi
yapmak durumunda kalıyorsunuz mesela
mecburen yapabileceğiniz her işi yapmak
durum
undadır arkadaşlar
oluş sürecimin en derinlikleri Ay benim
depresyonlara girmelerimin en
derinlikleri burada başlıyor çok ama
inanın bırakmaya Bırakmadan önce çok
direndim çok çok direndim ve Bırakmadan
önce yine tiyatro yaptım arkadaşlar çok
uzun süre yine tiyatro yaptım ama
olmadığını anladığım anda bıraktım
tiyatroy
u böyle ailemin yanına geri döndüm
Mersin'e
Arkadaşlar orada kütüphanecilik mi
yapmadım
Sigortacılık mı yapmadım kapı kapı gezip
insanlara Hayat sigortasını yapmadım
bankada mı çalışmadım
öğretmenlik mi yapmadım işte bu ne
deniyor şey marka ismi vermeyeyim krem
Müren makyaj makyaj şeylerimi satmadım
Yapmadığım şey kalmadı
Evet ben bunları yapıyorum ama bunları
yapma sebebim ve bunları yaparken de hep
bir kenara para koyuyordum arkadaşlar
Çünkü o bir kenara koyduğum para benim
İstanbul'a geri dönüş
bileti Benim birkaç ay İstanbul'daki
ikramı karşılayacaktı hep diyordum ki
ben dedim tekrar tiyatroya geri
döneceğim ve bu süre zarfında bir
kenarında paranın olması gerekiyor
kapılardan çevrildim işte iş yerlerine
gidip insanların kapısını çalıyordum
işte Merhaba Bensu şu bankadan geliyorum
üstte Hayat sigortasıyla alakalı görmek
istiyorum işte Çok affedersiniz küfürler
mi yemedim Onun dışında insanlar böyle
küçümseyerek bir bakmadılar çok çok çok
çok çok çok büyük şeyler yaşadım
aslında
böyle oldu
Rabbin
sana bu Rabbin seni seviyorsun sonuçta
sen kötü bir insan değilsin sana bunları
yaşat
masının bir zeki bir kızsın sen al bu
hikayeleri bu yaşadığın şeyleri cebine
koy ya bunları
yap ya da bunları bir
gün Aslında bunu
düşündüğünü Ha bir de ben spor salonunda
da çalıştım spor salonu üyeliği sattım
sana bir gün dedi ki Nurdan Hanım dedi
Mersin dedi en böyle işlek caddesine şey
koyacağız tam koyacağız Sen gelen gidene
şey dağıt
acaksın bu el broşürleri dağıtacaksın
ilkokul arkadaşlarım orada ortaokul
arkadaşlarım orada lise arkadaşlarım
orada bütün işte tanıdığım herkes orada
beni şöyle zannediyorlar Nurdan
İstanbul'a gitti tiyatrocu oldu falan
zannediyorlar ama ben hiçbir şeyi
başaramamışım geri dönmüşüm dersine en
ilanı dağıtıyorum işte spor salonu
üyeliği
spor salonu üyeliği ister misiniz diye
insanları el ilanı dağıtıyorum ve
arkadaşlar çok samimi söylüyorum eğer
ben Mersin'de kütüphanecilik yapmasaydım
var ya
çıkmazdı
Eğer ben o spor salonunda çalışmamış
olsaydım kendimi Öz güvenim gelmezdi de
şu an işte telefonla arayıp ya da
karşıma çıkan her insana
Yani bu oynayalım mı İşte şunu şöyle
yapalım mı diyemezdim
bankada çalışmamış o Sigortacılık
yapmamış olsaydım inanın
sponsorluk bu Filistin hakkında
konuşmalıyız oyunumuzda sponsor aradığım
dönemde çatır çatır gibi insanlardan
para isteyemez bu arada
Yani şunu hayatın boyunca herkes
önerdiğim bir şeyi
işinin geçmesini
asla girer arkadaşlar birkaç gün geçince
unutuyorsunuz Birileri bir şey söylüyor
birisini oradan geçiyorsunuz Ayşe fikir
mi Bu fikir mi derken o kalıyor ben
karar verdikten sonra hemen
Instagram'dan bir sayfa açtım tiyatro
Bulut
tek başına Aslında çamaşır suyu pijama
yorgan üzerinde elimdeki telefondan
Instagram adresi açtım tiyatro Ankebut
çok böyle sanki dergi veriyormuşuz işte
şeyimiz bu şirketimiz varmış gibi açtım
onu ve bir tane ay hiç de şey yapmayı da
bilmem O kalmadan manadan Eee ne derler
o Akış
motosuyla hem berbat afişini yapıp
Nurdan
Aldanma tanınıyormuşum gibi Nurdan ablam
ya inceden tiyatro dersleri şu tarihte
başlıyor şu şu şuraya başvuruda
bulunabilirsiniz diye bir afiş paylaştım
ondan sonra
yapıyormuş gibi birkaç saat sonra biri
geldi ama o birkaç yazdı O biri yazdı ya
ben evde nasıl zıplıyorum nasıl
zıplıyorum bir
kişi ya sanki şey ee ben bir salonuna
çıktım tiyatro dersi vereceğim de Salonu
binlerce kişi doldurmuş zıplıyorum
anne
o kayıt oldu ya öyle bana bir heyecan
geldi
[Müzik]
ne oluyor dedim ya Dalga mı geçiyor
birisi benimle
dalga kayıt oldu sonra ertesi gün bir
kişi daha kolay 5 kişi aldım listeme
Çünkü bir de altına şey yazmışım
kontenjama 5 kişiyle sınırlıdır
Ondan sonra 5 kişiyi aldım derse ama
diyorum ki Allah Allah ya Ne oluyor
ders 14 Şubat'ta olacak hiç unutmuyorum
14 Şubat'ta olacak diyorum ki bunlar
benimle dalga geçti hiçbir derse
gelmeyecek değil mi böyle şey sanki
böyle takım elbise giydim Online'da işte
ekranı kapattım böyle Bekliyorum yani
kalksam İstiklal Marşı okusam okurum
böyle bekliyorum o kadar
heyecan dersi yaptık sevgili
arkadaşlar diyorlar ya benim böyle
ekranı kapatıp o ders yaptığım alanda
zıplayasım geliyor
derse geldiğinden
geldikleri dersin beğendiklerini
başkalarını anlatmışlar ya
O başkaları da mesaj attılar ne zaman
yeni sınıf atıyorsunuz arkadaşım size
gelmiş çok beğenmişsinizdir ben de
dersinize gelmek istiyorum Bana bir
enerji geldi bir şey geldi şımarıklık
geldi Hemen bir sınıf daha açtım ya
inanın O da doğdu biliyor musunuz O da
doğdu ama benim kendime asla inancım yok
şey diyorum ben bu ikinci
[Müzik]
şeyi paylaşırım kayıt almıyoruz komuta
canım nasıl olmuştu falan diye bir şey
paylaşırım diyorum yani Neyse ondan
sonra o da doğdu sevgili arkadaşlar
son gitmeni benim bu arada başka bir
eğitmenimiz yok Benim verdiğim dersler
bir buçuk senede tam tamına 500
öğrenciye ulaştı
500 öğrenci
şimdi bunda kelimelerle ifade ediyorum
ya aklım almıyor biliyor musunuz
çıldıracak gibi oluyorum
[Müzik]
ne hatırlıyorum Şimdi 500 öğrenciye
ulaşmışız bakın inanın 500'den de
fazladır hava atmayın diye 500'e
yuvarladım yani çok
ciddi sınıfta Allah size kesinlikle
yardımcı oluyor
Aslında sevgili arkadaşlar dedim ki
şimdi 500 tane öğrencim var
yaklaşık 100 yine de çok samimiyim
İstanbul'da olduklarından dolayı
yaşıyorum şimdi görüştüğüm zaman
Bir de önünde şeyi var öğretmen olanlar
aralarında eğitimci olanlar bilir
siniz bakıyorlar ya sizin sanki
yapamayacağınız şey yokmuş gibi
zannediyorlar ve onların verdiği öyle
bir gaz oluyor ki Allah hepsinden razı
olsun bana ded
iler ki güzel dersler biliyorsunuz o
falan filan ama düz şey yapalım mı Siz
bir tiyatro oyunu yazın Biz de sizi
destekleyelim mi bir tiyatro oyunu yapın
dediler
falan hala daha benim böyle kendime olan
ödüllerim gelmiş değil Çünkü Evet 500
tane öğrenci gelmiş bir buçuk senede
ama acaba şöyle bir iki koltuk mu sığar
Çünkü biz zamanında konu komşuyu
toplamıştık Salonu doldurmak için yoldan
insanlar çevirmiştik Adam diyor ki Yok
benim işim var işe gideceğim
abi kapılardan insanlar
[Müzik]
diyorum Neyse hangi oyunla başlayalım
hangi oyunla başlayalım benim işte o
kütüphanecilik yaparken üzerinde
çalıştığım Filistin hakkında
konuşmalıyız oyunu
Ben dedim Bundan başlayacağım çünkü o
zaman Ramazan ayınıza Geçen sene Ramazan
ayında yine ne yazık ki Filistin çok
kötü bir muameleye maruz kalmıştı yine
Her ramazan olduğu gibi
Ben normalde her Ramazan Filistin bu
durumuna çok üzülürüm ama geçen sene
bana farklı bir üzüntü geldi Ne bileyim
işi yapmam gerekiyor dedim bir şey
yapmam gerekiyor
farklı Beynimde
Ne oldu ben onu bitirmiş miydim Çünkü
üzerinden Çok zaman geçti ya ve bu
ışıkları
bitirmedi sıyırdım elimi şöyle Sildim
hemen gittim eski Bilgisayarıma açtım
onu buldum oyun işte 10 saniyelik diye
planlamışım 7-8 tanesini yazıp
bırakmışım hemen oturdum diğer
sahnelerini de yazmaya
başladım hemen Bu arada Onun öncesinde
bir komedi oyunu
yazıyor komedi oyunu ile giderim diye
düşünüyorum komedi oyunu yazıyorum
şehirde deminki videoda da söylediği
gibi akşam
20 saat birimi baktım
ki yani oyun Bana kendimi yazdırmadı ama
o bulaşıktan Ellerimi sıyırdığım gibisin
oyununun sonunu yazmaya başladığından
var ya takır takır
takır Tabi onun zaman
ı İşte o oyunun zaman
ı güzeldir yazdım
sonrasında dedim ki Ama bunun yapmak
için paraya ihtiyacımız var bizim bir
sponsor bulunur
sonra bulmak için arkadaşlar o kadar
uğraştım o kadar ama ben eğer
o kapının önünde o spor salonunun önünde
o broşürleri satmamış olsaydım daha
konuş olsaydım o kapılardan girip de
insanlara işte sigorta hayat sigortası
satmaya çalışmasaydım o bankada O işte
insanların
egosuna maruz kalmamış olsaydım kapı
kapı gezip sponsor bulamazdım ya
Elhamdülillah diyorum ben
ilkileri onları yaşamışım İyi ki böyle
saçma sapan şeylere maruz
kalmış moralim bozulacaktı motivasyonum
sıfırdan Bu oyun yapamayacağım galiba
diyecektim ama yer mi Anadolu çocuğu
bana işler mi ya dedim suratlarında
ekşitmeleri ya da
ilgilenmiyoruz demeleri ya da işte benim
bir şey yapamayacağıma dair böyle
Kaşlarını kaldırıp imada bulunmaları
kadın başında mı bu oyunu yapacaksınız
falan demeleri bana işler mi
Arkadaşlar nereden baksanız Belki 50
kapıya gittim
bir kapı ya ben çok büyük bir market
zincirinin sahibinden bile randevu alıp
dedim ki ya bizim bir tiyatro oyunumuz
var işte siz de market olarak bize
sponsor olur musunuz
beni kapıdan çevirmeleri işte benimle
dalga geçmeleri
bana
böyle kurum var önümde hangi Vakıf
F var bak
neredeyse Arkadaşlar eşime de
çok teşekkür rezil de ediyor sizi Vezir
de beni Vezir etti Çünkü ben her kapıdan
döndüğümde O da bir arabayla beni kapıda
bekliyordu belki de
ben o tarafa geçerdim Onun da bana çok
etkisi oldu bu süre zarfında ben
vakıflarda dolaşla dolanmaktan işte bir
şeyler yapmaya çalışmaktan Evde ne yemek
yaptım Ne temizlik yaptım işte efendime
söyleyeyim Ne bir çamaşır yıkadım ne bir
şey yaptım adam kendi kendine yaptı
kendi kendine yedi işte Bana da yaptı
Benim de Karnıma doyurdu
Hani gerçekten
[Alkış]
o yani eş seçimi çok önemli
sonrasında sevgili arkadaşlar tam
notlarımı yine kaybettiğim bir anda tam
yine Tamam burada Hasan galiba yine
kayboluyorsun dediğim bir anda böyle
filmlerde olur ya Allah'ım bana bir kapı
aç dersin işte Ömer hocam siz filmleri
iyi bilirsiniz Hani filmleri filmlerde
böyle bir rüzgar şimşek çakar bir perde
yerinden oynar mı diye bir müzik gelir
Sonra bir yerden bir ilham gelir ya da
bir kapı açılır geldim sana yardım
etmeye der ya Ben öyle bir şey
bekliyordum açtım elimi dua ettim öyle
bir şey olmadı ama çok böyle ağlayarak
böyle nasıl samimi bir şekilde dua
ediyorum
böyle bir şey olmadı arkadaşlar ancak
timing'de tutturamamışız yaklaşık 1 saat
sonra telefonum çaldı
[Müzik]
ya 1 saat sonra telefon çaldı telefonda
bir kurum adı verebiliyor muyuz ya ben
kurum adı verebiliyorsak Vereyim mi
Vereyim ya İnsan ve Medeniyet Hareketi
candır
beni ara dedi ki Nurdan Hanım dedi Siz
dedi tiyatro oyunu yapıyormuşsunuz Biz
duyduk biz size destek olmak isteriz
dedi Dedim ki ben size başvurmadım ki
bana bak Ben bir hava var ben size
başvurmadım ki dedim ki siz
başvurmamışsınız ama dosyanız elimize
geldi şimdi ben şimdi her şey diyorum Ne
dosyası ya bizim dosyaya kap yaptıracak
Paramız yoktu ki şimdi o şey yaptırmıştı
göndermiş arkadaşlar birisi kim olduğunu
bilmiyorum şimdi ben 1 milyon kişiye
gönderdim ya WhatsApp'tan bu dosyayı
Online olarak
belki de buraday
sa Allah daim duamda birisi çıkmış
gitmiş ona ozalitçiden kap yaptır
mış ve böyle en pahalı kapı yaptırmış
yaptırmış git
mişiz oyunu Ben kefilim kim olduğunu
Bana söylemiyorlar Ama gerçekten demek
ki gerçekten çok yardımda kalbi
gerçekten çok temiz kim olduğunu bile
söylenmesini
isteme Ben bunu
keke de kullanabilirsiniz
ve ondan sonra beni aradılar Ben de bu
oyunun etkinliği istediler oyunum
metnini hemen bir gün
içerisinde Hani bunlar çok şey inanılmaz
şeyler Normalde bir yere başvurursunuz o
yerden size bir desteğin geri dönse
haftalar aylara bulur
destek
öyle böyle bir meblağa değil yani bana
göre çok büyük paraydı onunla nasıl ya
dedim gerçekten Çünkü yönetmene para
verilecek işte ee
oyun dekoru olacak işte ışıkçıya para
verilecek dekorcun ya para verebilecek
Onun dışında onunla alakalı görünen
görünümlü Yani o kadar çok gider Siz
şimdi Filistin hakkında konuşmalıyız ve
gelenler varsa arkada bir tane dekor var
ben çıktım oynadım zannetiyorsunuz o
kadar kolay değil o kadar altında
altında altında bir sürü gideri var ki
pembe Medeniyet Hareketi bana o Bedeli
verdi ve ben İvedik ile oyunumu yapmaya
başladım
bakın
Belki de ben gidip de mala yani mala
yani Ne anlatayım orada diyebilirdim
Çünkü ben yaşadığım için buraya geldim
gerçekten
aramak
istiyor sevgili arkadaşlar o yüzden size
böyle ben şey demek istemiyorum Hayatta
en nefret ettiğim şey de nasihat vermek
Çünkü bana zamanında nasihat verildiği
zaman böyle karşımdakini boğazlayasım
geliyordu
bana yapabileceğime dair umut ver bana
huzur ver ya
huzur vermek istemiyorum sadece şunu
söylemek istiyorum
tozdan da
dua edin ve şükürler olsun İyi ki
kayboldun değil İyi ki ben hala diyorum
ki umarım önünde kaybolacağım daha çok
zaman vardır
Peki oyunda ya da ondan
O yüzden kaybolmak sevgili arkadaşlar
Dünyadaki en güzel şey çok ciddi
söylüyorum eğer ben kaybolmamış olsaydım
tabi asla şu anki şu oyunu yapabilecek
duruma gelemezdim
anlamına gelmesin Ben sadece
Demin Size anlattığım gibi 0
buna hiç kimse olmayan
[Müzik]
bir insan olarak Yarın Ankara'da bakın
Ankara'dan da hiç kimseyi tanımam hiç
kimseyi Ankara'da MEB Şura salonunda
1200 kişilik salonda 1200 tane bile
hesap
lıyorum
O yüzden çok net söylüyorum
kaybolduğunuz zaman yapabileceğiniz tek
şey şükretmek diyorum daha fazla
konuşmak ve sizi sıkmak istemiyorum
hepinizi Allah'a emanet ediyorum Çok
teşekkür ederim
[Alkış]